[Music]
in today's movie preview we talk about
the probably most popular anti-hero of
our time Deadpool was about to embark on
his third movie Adventure in this video
we will give you an insight into the
potential plot the cast and the
production so stay tuned and have fun
with our new original episode
although filming has not started yet
there is countless speculation about
what the storyline could turn out to be
well at least that's been true for the
last few weeks with lead actor Ryan
Reynolds raising the promo for the film
to a new level in late September in an
at first remarkable video the actor
ironically talks about how many thoughts
he had about Deadpool 3 in the
background Hugh Jackman eventually walks
through the screen and has announced
that he will indeed return to his
legendary role as Wolverine as they sit
on the couch together in a different
video they promise to answer many open
fan questions this gives us a clear idea
of the direction the plot will take
after all the surprise appearance of
Wolverine also changes the speculations
regarding the film's storyline so first
let's begin with Jackman's role and the
part his character could take with
Wolverine and Deadpool two entirely
contrasting characters are going to meet
while one is a goofy anti-hero as well
as a brutal mercenary the other is a
rather Grim but Loyal Fighter with his
heart at the right place still both can
be said to have a somewhat hot temper
let's get to the the first aspect of
Wolverine's story actually he already
died in his last movie Logan released in
2017. where he made it supposedly last
appearance however you also have to keep
in mind that this movie was set in 2029
the Deadpool franchise though is set in
the present and therefore an appearance
of the superhero is easily achievable a
very obvious hint as to how exactly the
two will meet was posted by Reynolds
himself on Twitter a while back there he
claimed that Deadpool 3 was meant to be
a road movie in the style of roshamon
with the two main characters before
Disney's acquisition of fox rashamon is
a 1950 Japanese Thriller made by the
iconic director Akira Kurosawa it tells
the story of a Samurai's murder from the
perspective of several people and
depending on the point of view the story
differs in some cases significantly thus
one story would likely have been told
from Deadpool's point of view and the
other from Wolverines during a road trip
some people believe that the road move
he is still in the works and that the
two lead characters are going on a road
trip from the fox Universe to the MCU so
to speak after all neither care
character has been featured there yet
cameos from various characters from the
X-Men and Fantastic Four franchises
could likewise be involved Deadpool may
also hunt down various X-Men characters
and kill all the superheroes in order to
well clean up the partially confusing
timeline of the X-Men Universe evidence
that Deadpool is quite capable of wiping
out an entire universe already exists in
the comics in 2011 author Cullen Bunn
published a four issue miniseries titled
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe in
the first part Deadpool is forcefully
admitted to the ravencroft Institute by
the X-Men to receive treatment for his
mental illness his doctor however is
none other than psychoman who is known
for brainwashing his patients yet he
commits a fatal mistake as instead of
freeing Deadpool from his inner voice
Emily replaces it with a new one that
permanently urges him to eliminate
absolutely everything and everyone no
sooner said than done not only does he
kill psychoman but also the entire
Fantastic Four in the following parts he
also deals with Spider-Man whom he
coldly murders by shooting him in the
head he assembled Avengers debate on how
to proceed but Deadpool quickly blows up
the Avengers Tower killing the majority
of the heroes Spider-Man's morning loved
ones eventually hired Taskmaster and
ordered him to kill Wade Wilson AKA
Deadpool oh by the way Wolverine appears
in the comics as well he along with all
the other Heroes also falls victim to
Deadpool and is decapitated after
further countless deaths and an
appearance of the Puppet Master the
comic reaches its end in a scene where
Deadpool confronts the comics writers he
finally turns to the readers to inform
them he will find them soon enough as
well a pretty freaky but definitely not
unrealistic idea for Deadpool 3. what do
you think of the concept of Deadpool in
contrast to the comic book causing a
huge Massacre among the X-Men and then
fleeing with Wolverine into the MCU or
do you guys think Deadpool and
Wolverines transition into the MCU will
be entirely different perhaps in such a
way that the two might even fight each
other feel free to drop us a line in the
comments in fact Deadpool's transitioned
into the MCU should be an easy one for
those in charge at Marvel no matter what
it ends up being since the character
often breaks the fourth wall and speaks
to the audience there is a certain meta
level in the film series that makes just
about anything possible Deadpool could
likely even get away with looking into
the camera right at the beginning and
saying I'm part of the MCU now that
would perhaps be a bit trite but it
helps to keep in mind that just about
anything is viable in the Deadpool
franchise no matter how absurd it may
seem at first
at least as important for a Deadpool
movie as a crazy spectacular story is
the R rating so far the two Deadpool
movies from 20th Century Fox have been
characterized by badass action and black
humor they have always been given the
infamous R rating in the U.S which
forbids viewing by anyone under 18.
after Disney's acquisition of fox many
fans feared the Deadpool would fall
victim to censorship by Disney after all
the family-friendly Corporation has a
reputation for not Distributing
excessively violent or adult films under
its name the big relief for fans of
adult action came from Disney boss Bob
Iger as well as Marvel boss Kevin feig
both have confirmed in the past that
they will not back away from violence
and humor in the third installment which
automatically means that Deadpool 3 will
become the first R-rated MCU movie feek
describes Deadpool as a completely
different character compared to other
MCU superheroes thus justifying the
r-rating exception the chemistry between
Deadpool and Wolverine on the one hand
and the usual brutality on the other
hand let us hope for promising third
part and we are eager to see which plot
the responsible parties will opt for in
the end for more news on this subject we
suggest you check out our weekly news
format on our Channel
as for the cast two people have stood
out so far Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman not only are the two per se
already quite popular actors in
Hollywood but they also perform their
roles as Deadpool and Wolverine at their
best Ryan Reynolds is more or less the
embodiment of his character Deadpool and
in addition to the film series he is
known for films such as free guy and six
underground Hugh Jackman already has a
noticeably larger filmography to his
name and has also played many famous
roles such as in Christopher Nolan's The
Prestige and in Les Miserables where he
played the part of Jean Valjean indeed
Deadpool and Wolverine are almost the
only confirmed characters who will make
an appearance in Deadpool 3. merely
Leslie uggums as Wade's roommate blind
Al has been officially announced so far
appearances of zazi Beats as Domino or
Josh Brolin as cable seem to be quite
feasible again but sadly official
information is still missing both beats
and Rob Delaney who played Peter have at
least publicly expressed their interest
in returning
let's now turn our attention to the
production of Deadpool 3. for a long
time it was actually not known whether
there will be a Deadpool sequel by
Disney at all and whether this will then
also take place in the MCU then in
December 2019 Reynolds himself announced
that a third Deadpool movie was in the
works with a whole crew at Marvel
Studios in October 2020 the active
search for more screenwriters began
which concluded with the signing of
Wendy molyneux and Lizzie mullinu Logan
they were later succeeded by Rhett Reese
and Paul wernick were in charge of the
present version of the script with the
contribution of Ryan Reynolds Sean Levy
will direct Deadpool 3. the 54 year old
Canadian has already directed movies
such as free guy the atom project and
Night at the Museum and was also
involved in stranger things in addition
to Kevin feig Ryan Reynolds who was
involved in many behind-the-scenes
processes is also acting as producer
shooting which originally should have
started this year will then kick off in
Vancouver in January 2023 and the
theatrical release of Deadpool 3 is
scheduled for November 8th 2024 her
that was our original for this week did
you enjoy the preview and what are your
expectations for the third Deadpool
movie let us know in the comments and be
sure to subscribe and give the video a
thumbs up if you liked it see you next
time
[Music]